[Música]
al menos 12 muertos y decenas de heridos
dejaron nuevos bombardeos en la ciudad
ucraniana de zaporiya que las
autoridades atribuyen a misiles rusos el
ataque se produjo después de que una
explosión el sábado causar al colapso
parcial de un puente que une la
Península de crimea con Rusia
Corea del Norte lanzó otros dos misiles
balísticos cerca de Japón Aunque según
el gobierno nipón los artefactos cayeron
fuera de su zona económica exclusiva es
El séptimo lanzamiento de este tipo por
parte de pyongyang en menos de una
semana
a un mes de las elecciones de medio
término en Estados Unidos miles de
mujeres se manifestaron en varias
ciudades a favor de los derechos
sexuales y reproductivos el tema del
aborto es clave para los republicanos y
los demócratas tras la reciente
anulación del fallo Road versus
Bienvenidos a las noticias de fin de
semana en France 24 Yo soy Daniel
hablandona damos inicio a este
Informativo en Ucrania en donde al menos
12 muertos dejaron nuevos bombardeos en
la ciudad Sur oriental de zaporiya esto
según la gobernación regional otras
decenas de personas incluidos niños
resultaron heridos mientras que unos
cinco edificios residenciales fueron
arrasados y otros parcialmente
destruidos esa ciudad que alberga la
planta de energía nuclear más grande de
Europa en las últimas semanas ha estado
bajo el asedio de Rusia que controla
partes de la región pero no la capital
el jueves murieron 18 personas en el más
reciente ataque
seguimos en esta región el presidente
ruso Vladimir Putin firmó un decreto
para reforzar la seguridad del puente de
kerch que une a su país con la Península
de crimea una explosión ocurrida el
sábado y de la que no se ha reclamado
responsabilidad provocó el colapso
parcial de la infraestructura y dejó al
menos tres muertos según Moscú este
puente de 19 kilómetros y que une a los
mares negro y a soft es el más largo de
Europa y símbolo de la anexión rusa de
crimea en 2014 también es una ruta de
suministro clave para sus fuerzas que
luchan en el sur de Ucrania
cambiamos de información y vamos a Japón
que condenó y calificó de inaceptables
los lanzamientos de misiles de Corea del
Norte cerca de su territorio después del
Séptimo de ellos ocurrido el domingo en
la madrugada Aunque otros dos misiles de
corto alcance dirigidos a las aguas
orientales japonesas no cayeron en la
zona económica exclusiva el gobierno
nipón considera una amenaza para la
seguridad regionales o lanzamientos que
además se producen después de ejercicios
navales en aguas cercanas a la Península
norcoreana en los que ha participado un
portaaviones estadounidense de
propulsión nuclear cuya presencia en la
zona ha sido críticada por pyongyang
desde finales de septiembre en este
corto periodo de tiempo han lanzado
misiles siete veces intensificando sus
acciones directas y provocativas estas
acciones de Corea del Norte son una
amenaza para la paz y la seguridad de
nuestro país región y comunidad
internacional y absolutamente no puede
ser tolerado y nos venimos para la
región de América miles de manifestantes
salieron a las calles de Estados Unidos
a conmemorar la marcha de las mujeres
pidiendo principalmente la protección
del aborto sin embargo este año tuvieron
un tinte político de Cara a las
elecciones de medio término que se
celebrarán en menos de un mes y en las
cuales la interrupción del embarazo
juega un papel crucial el informe es de
Andrés triviño
aumenta la atención electoral en Estados
Unidos a tan solo un mes de las
elecciones de medio término en las que
se renovarán las dos cámaras del
congreso las calles de diferentes
ciudades del país se llenaron de
manifestantes marchando a favor del
aborto
necesitamos unirnos y luchar contra lo
que está sucediendo otra vez el proceso
gubernamental y lo que estamos pensando
es que debemos apoyar a las mujeres
estadounidenses para que tomen
decisiones por sí mismas
desde la victoria de Donald Trump en
2016 anualmente se realiza la marcha de
las mujeres en todo el país y este año
tuvo un objetivo claro manifestar el
rechazo la histórica anulación de
robertswave la cual puso fin a la
protección del derecho al aborto a nivel
federal y dio como resultado que 13 de
los 50 estados ya prohíban la
interrupción del embarazo los demócratas
han hecho del aborto un tema central
para su campaña de las elecciones de
medio término de este 8 de noviembre los
resultados de los comicios decidirán si
el partido del presidente Joe biden
conservará el poder en el congreso o si
los republicanos logran quitárselo
con las próximas elecciones de mitad de
término es de Vital importancia
recordarle a la gente que salga y bote
para que de esta manera podamos
preservar nuestras libertades básicas y
codificar
con suerte codificar la igualdad
matrimonial y cualquier otro de los
demás
Además del aborto la economía también es
un tema fundamental para las elecciones
que se acercan en un momento donde la
inflación supera el 8% y los precios de
los combustibles han ido aumentando a
niveles históricos
seguimos en el continente de americano
Haití solito solicitó la ayuda de tropas
internacionales en su lucha contra las
bandas criminales en plena crisis de
abastecimiento y un nuevo brote de
cólera que mató al menos a ocho personas
una alianza de pandillas tomó el control
de la principal terminal de combustibles
de Puerto Príncipe lo que complica aún
más la asistencia médica y el reparto de
productos básicos le abren los ampliado
la comunidad internacional se solidariza
con Haití los países miembros de la
organización de los Estados Americanos
aprobaron una resolución a favor del
restablecimiento de la seguridad y la
democracia en la nación caribeña lo que
podría abrir un nuevo capítulo para este
país inmerso en una violenta crisis
socioeconómica y política y afectado por
un nuevo brote de cólera
la adopción de una resolución Nunca es
un fin en sí mismo son los unos y los
otros los que tienen que ponerse de
acuerdo para que las capacidades y los
medios estén allí para que todos los
deseos de este texto se traduzcan en
realidad las pandillas siempre
ejercieron Un poder considerable en
Haití pero tras el asesinato del
presidente de Rubio en el movies en
julio de 2021 este poder aumentó a
medida que luchan por controlar más
territorios matando a cientos de
haitianos en los últimos meses
expulsando a unas 20.000 personas de sus
hogares el viernes el consejo de
ministros autorizó al Primer Ministro
arrial Audi a Solitario obtener ese
despliegue de una Fuerza Armada
extranjera una intervención que muchos
haitianos rechazan
es una acción antipatrótica normalmente
el país no está bajo tutela es un país
independiente
me pregunto que es Ángel nadie le votó
no está elegido no tiene legitimidad No
tiene derecho
la vuelta de la ayuda militar
internacional Haití es también un tema
polémico por la última misión de las
fuerzas de paz de la ONU que se terminó
en 2017 después de 13 años en el país
Los cascos azules Fueron señalados por
agresiones y abusos sexuales y por
provocar una epidemia de cólera que
costó la vida de que así Diez mil
personas
y en otras noticias del día cuatro
semanas después de la muerte de Max a
mini de 22 años las protestas
antigubernamentales lideradas por
mujeres siguen extendiéndose por todo
Irán las fuerzas de seguridad se
enfrentan a las manifestantes con
violencia hiriendo a cientos de ellas
pero las mujeres siguen transmitiendo su
mensaje
en el centro de Teherán las escolares
corean muerte a jamenei el líder supremo
de la República de Irán las comisarías
permanecen envueltas en llamas y un
anciano muestra su apoyo a los
manifestantes
[Música]
Estas son las imágenes de Irán que se
difunden en las redes sociales mientras
continúan las manifestaciones en todo el
país cuatro semanas después de que
marcha a mínini muriera tras ser
detenida por la policía de la moral
iraní el presidente que acusa a las
fuerzas extranjeras de provocar esta
revuelta nacional emitió un comunicado
el enemigo pensó que podría seguir sus
deseos dentro de la universidad sin
saber que nuestros estudiantes y
profesores estaban despiertos y no
permitirían que los falsos sueños del
enemigo se hicieran realidad Este es el
mayor desafío al que se han enfrentado
los dirigentes clericales en años ya que
mujeres de todas las edades se
manifiestan desafiando al poder pero las
manifestaciones masivas se enfrentan a
la violencia de las fuerzas de seguridad
en mashup una joven yaz inconsciente
tras haber sido presuntamente tiroteada
aquí un conductor también ha recibido un
disparo mientras iba en su vehículo como
este hombre que cambió el lema la
policía al Servicio del pueblo por la
policía mata al pueblo o este cartel ya
no tenemos Vamos a luchar
terminamos este informativo con noticias
deportivas el neerlandés Max verstapping
se consagró campeón del mundial de la
Fórmula 1 tras vencer en el gran premio
de Japón en una carrera marcada por los
accidentes y las interrupciones por la
lluvia en el circuito de suzuka el
piloto de Red Bull de 25 años revalido
del título logrado el año pasado después
de que su más cercano competidor el
monegasco Charles leclerc fuera
sancionado por salirse de la pista
así damos final a este Informativo en
France 24 recuerde quedarse con nosotros
también puede ver más información en
France 24.com
[Música]